hey guys you know those times when you
talk with someone and then you realize
they have bad breath i mean it stinks
those times where you just move a little
bit and they get closer you just wish
they would stop talking but they don't
because they don't even realize they
have bad breath and you're just like oh
my goodness
nobody likes that not even you not me
nobody likes bad breath the problem is
most people don't realize it including
you
yeah you might have bad breath and you
don't even realize it so in this video
i'm going to give you my seven best tips
seven ways that you can keep your breath
fresh all day let's get to it
[Music]
hey if it's your first time here my name
is daniel and welcome to dlm men's
lifestyle subscribe if you haven't done
so already
now let's start with the first proven
way
to get rid of bad breath
brush your tongue
look if you just always brush your teeth
but you don't brush all that gunk off on
your tongue
what's gonna happen
it's gonna stay there and it's gonna
stink
no scrape your tongue clean every time
you brush your teeth
[Music]
brush your teeth after every meal
be honest
how many times a day do you brush your
teeth
once twice
no you gotta brush your teeth after
every meal then you will be sure that
you will always have good looking teeth
and your breath will be fresh you can
even take your toothbrush to work why
not
avoid a dry mouth it doesn't matter who
you are what position you are how rich
you are how poor you are where you live
your race it doesn't matter
every single human if you have a dry
mouth
only two things are true number one it
is dry number two
it stinks so drink more water
eat the right food if you're not careful
if you make a habit of eating the wrong
food then you will always have bad
breath so just know what kind of food to
avoid most of the time especially with
important meetings
for example i love coffee i drink two to
three cups of coffee a day because i
love it but coffee also causes bad
breath so what i do just in between
every cup of coffee i make sure that i
drink water and i rinse it out after a
cup of coffee
other foods that also causes bad breath
are garlic onions dairy products peanut
butter horseradish and pasta sauce
floss at least once a day guys if you
don't do this it's just gross i mean you
eat food it gets stuck in your teeth it
gets bad it starts to rot and it will
stink not only that it will also cause
infection
now flush your teeth take good care of
your teeth
stop smoking this is another one another
thing that i talk about on my channel a
lot and guys it is so annoying when
someone comes standing next to you they
talk and you just smell that tobacco i
mean it's terrible
not only does it cause bad breath
but it also damages your gums and you
will have a yellow smile because it
stains your teeth you can stop if you
really want to so why don't you
now just a bonus tip when you're out and
about always keep mints or gum in your
car
it's better than nothing if you realize
you have bad breath
it will help i always keep these
fishermen's friends in my car because
of course i love fishing and i never
want to have bad breath now if you want
more tips anything to do with men's
lifestyle check out one of these videos
here and i'll see you there and always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours